women versus men like what what barriers
do we need to be moved because that's my
statement I'm not I'm not stating
anything else I'm stating women versus
men it's very silly like so so what bear
it's not a fair question it's how is
that a fair question at proving the
point of why let people especially black
women other people who are anybody who's
not white why we hear feminism and we
don't want that label because it means
it means that you've already gone to a
pinnacle of whatever you think your
happiness needs or whatever your
survivalist needs are when there are
people on lower end who are trying to
survive who are trying to get to a point
of what should be normal
um based on what other people have